- Hello and welcome to ED
Talks with Khan Academy
where we talk to influential
people in the education space
about learning and teaching.
Today, we are pleased to
welcome Dr. Barbara Oakley
who is celebrating the
launch of her new book,
"Uncommon Sense Teaching,"
and we will talk more
about that coming up.
Before we get started,
I wanted to remind you that
Khan Academy is a nonprofit
and we are able to do our work
providing a free world-class
education to anyone, anywhere
thanks to donations from folks like you.
So, if you are in a place
where you are able to do that,
you can find a link right
at the top of our website
to make any kind of donation
that helps us keep continuing this work.
Thank you very much.
In addition, over the COVID-19 pandemic,
we've had some sponsors
who have really helped us
to continue that learning and keep working
and making sure we're able
to provide that education
so we wanna in particular
thank Bank of America, AT&T,
Google.org, Novartis, Fastly
and General Motors, thank you.
Next, if you are looking for more
of these kinds of conversations,
you can find them via podcast.
Our Homeroom with Sal, The
Podcast features audio versions
of many of these chats we have had
so do check that out wherever
you get your podcasts from
and as I said in the beginning,
we are excited today to be
joined by Dr. Barbara Oakley
whose book, "Uncommon Sense Teaching,"
Practical Insights in Brain
Science to Help Students Learn
is out today.
We're gonna be talking a lot
about how research about
the brain helps inform us
about the things we should
do in our classrooms
to help more students learn more.
So, welcome, it's so nice to have you.
- Oh, it's good to be here Kristen.
- Great, so, to get things started,
I often like to talk to people
about how they got to
be experts in learning.
I know lots of people take
different varying paths
to get here, what was yours?
- Oh, I guess a bit different than some.
My father was a veterinarian
and so I grew up thinking,
"Whoa, I love animals,
I want to be a veterinarian
just like him,"
except that I couldn't do math at all
so, I finally realized
that I have to give up
on my childhood dream,
probably hoped that I did
a lot of cleaning of cages
when I was a kid
and that can really change your mind
about some aspects of veterinary science
but instead, I became a
professor of engineering.
So go figure, I did a lot of--
- Did you learn how to do math?
- I did learn how to do that
and actually, I didn't change
in my ability to do math
until I was 26-years-old and
I was getting out of the army
and I suddenly realized
that all my friends
who had a really good technical background
just had more doors open
for them professionally
and, I mean, I would
never trade the fact that
I really pursued my dream of
learning the language well
although my Russian is
now very, very rusty
unless I have a little bit of
wine or something like that
but we won't go there.
It comes right back at that point
but I realized that it
would be a good idea
for me to try to broaden my passions
instead of follow my passions
and that maybe I really
could start learning
in math and science.
And at that time, they didn't
have Khan Academy available.
It could have been so much easier for me.
So instead, I had to go to the university,
start with remedial high school algebra
and slowly begin climbing my way upwards
but the thing is, if you
just are slow and steady
and start at the lowest level
where you actually feel comfortable
and begin gradually
practicing day after day
after week, after even years,
you can achieve far more than you ever...
I mean, my high school algebra
teacher would have been like,
"You gotta be kidding me, her,
a professor of engineering?
You're joking."
I'm actually a distinguished
professor of engineering
and I even...
I'm a fellow in some engineering societies
and I publish in very good journals
and, I mean, I'm the real deal,
I'm not a fake engineering professor
but the higher I got, the
more I fell in love with math.
Although I do have to say that
I'm a very mischievous professor
because sometimes I will go
and look at some of Sal's tutorials,
I will put them together and
then I will go and present them
with a courtesy thank you to Sal,
but he just presents things so beautifully
that sometimes even I was
learning things at advanced levels
because he can help you
actually just understand
some of those fundamental
in actually quite simple concepts,
at least simple once he
gets done explaining things.
So, I think that we really
have not as educators
acknowledged the value of great teaching
and great explanations in
helping students to move forward
and be successful at
difficult areas like science,
technology, engineering and math.
- That totally makes sense
so, how did you take being
that professor of engineering
who I'm sure was publishing
about engineering
and start moving into thinking
about how to help more people learn
and thinking about brain science
and how to bring that into
our understanding of learning?
How did you make that connection or shift?
- Well, because my first degree
was in Slavic languages and literature,
I have always had a
broader set of interests
so it's not like, you have
to be in one discipline
or silo in your life,
I've been lucky enough to realize that
sometimes it's okay to
be in the humanity silo,
sometimes in the social sciences silo
and sometimes in the
more hard science silo
and so I've always liked writing
as well as doing math and engineering
and I kept that up even when
I was doing my dissertation
and even as I had my early years
as a professor of engineering,
of course I kept it secret
that I was still writing on the side
because other engineers
especially in academia
were not necessarily
on board with the idea
of being broader than just engineering.
But because I like to write,
I was always looking at
questions that interested me
and that led me to a lot of research
into what is going on
in cognitive psychology
and a good thing about
looking at a discipline
when you're trained in a
completely different discipline
is you can more easily see holes
and gaps in that discipline.
So, I saw a lot of great
research in cognitive psychology
and a lot of glaring holes
and assumptions that
really couldn't be made
because there was no solid
scientific foundation.
And I also worked and
learned as much as I could
about neuroscience and even genetics,
so, what do the hard sciences tell us
about how our brain is working?
So then, one day, one of my
students asked the question,
how did...
He found out about my
terrible past as a math monkey
and he said,
"How did you change your
brain to be successful
in math and science?"
And so I wrote him a little email
and then I thought, "I
like to write books,
why don't I write a book about this?
I can research it even more."
And that led to me beginning to work
in the discipline of education
and what I found is that
a lot of educators...
That there's sort of a disconnection,
it's like, I know how to
teach secondary mathematics
and I'm really good at
it and that's what I do
but they don't really look
at the connection of people
going out into the working world
with that secondary mathematics education
and whether it actually fits out there,
whether it actually builds a good bridge
for learning in science, engineering
and technology and mathematics
and so I found that there's,
I think an important
need for people like me
who help educators and help students
and teachers to see more concretely
the complex interconnection
between education,
neuroscience, cognitive psychology,
what's going on in the practical world
and tie that together in a
way that people can clearly
and easily see what's going on.
And that's sort of how
my work has emerged.
I think people just liked it so much,
it was very encouraging for me
and that kinda kept me going.
- That's great
and so your new book is,
"Uncommon Sense Teaching."
So, tell me about that title,
why is it uncommon sense?
- Oh, okay.
So, first I thought,
a lot of these ideas
are just common sense.
So, my colleague and co-author,
Beth Rogowsky is a K-12...
She's a teacher of
teachers who teach to K-12
but she has a lot of experience
herself in K-12 classrooms
and so, I had my bright idea, I was like,
"Beth, we should call our
book "Common Sense Teaching,"
and Beth about blew a gasket
because she said,
"A lot of these ideas, you may
think they're common sense,
but people are really not aware of them.
Sometimes it's simply not what is taught
in schools of pedagogy, even
though it is very well grounded
with profoundly effective
research from neuroscience
about how we think and learn."
So, I went away and stood for a while
because it's like, "Here, my
great idea was all shot down."
But Beth was quite right about that
and then finally, one day
it just popped into my head,
well, what about uncommon sense teaching?
And Beth wrote me back and she was like,
"Well, I didn't like the title
but I asked a bunch of friends
and they really liked it,
so, now I think I like it too."
So, that's how the topic came about.
- Can you give us an example of something
that seems like common
sense but maybe it's not?
That commonly used?
- Well, so, oh, there's so many.
So, you will often hear
from people who will say,
you don't need to learn that
because you can always look it up
and the reality is, let's say our French,
I love the sound of French,
I love French.
Could I speak French if I just
always went and looked it up
on Google Translate?
I mean, I wouldn't have
that neural structure,
I would have absolutely no
comprehension really of French
if I just always went and looked it up.
So, people might think,
Well, okay, I'll grant
you that for the language
but it's like this for
almost everything else.
Well, actually, it isn't.
You do not become an expert at anything
unless you have those key
ideas embedded in links
between neurons of long-term memory.
And that can only happen
through not only explanations,
but through your own active
practice with the material.
Even something as seemingly simple as,
"Well, I want you to compare
and contrast the French
and the Russian and the
American Revolutions."
Well, you could just think about it as,
"I can always go look it up."
But if you had to go
and look up when did each of those occur?
What were the key aspects?
Who were the key players?
All of these things, if
you had to go look that up
because you didn't bother to put anything
in your long-term memory,
you don't really understand
any of those fundamental concepts
and we've actually seen this play out
with things like students
who confuse the civil war
with civil rights
and they think that Abraham Lincoln
maybe knew Martin Luther King
because they didn't have
to memorize any dates
that are affiliated with anything.
So, building really advanced
higher level, Bloom's Taxonomy,
understanding of information
arises in a very important way
from our putting of
basic fundamental facts
into our long-term memory.
So, I mean, that's just one
example, I could probably give--
- Yeah, yeah.
So, I know, that's great.
So, that's the declarative
knowledge side of things.
In the book, you also talk
about procedural skills
and what kinds of things are
we learning from brain science
about being able to
learn procedural skills?
- So, the brain has almost
like two major super highways
that it uses to deposit information
in your long-term memory.
The first superhighway is
the declarative highway
or pathway and that goes
through the hippocampus.
And we've long known that
if you like happen to be
missing your hippocampus,
"Oh, you know, I put it
around here someplace."
If you're missing it,
you can't really depositive
things you've learned declaratively
into your long-term memory.
So, a very famous patient, Henry Molaison
had both of his hippocampi removed
and if you were introduced
to him, he would greet you
and he'd be a lovely man
and you walk out of the room
and then you wait a minute
or two, you walk back in
and he would not remember you
and you'd have to be reintroduced.
But let's say that you
walked in and met Henry
and you were a mischievous sort
and you had in your hand a pin.
I'm not suggesting to do this in real life
but actually, psychologists
have done this with patients
who are similar to Henry.
And you shook Henry's hand,
what would happen is, if you walked out
and you walk back in and you
introduced yourself again,
Henry would not know who you were
and he'd be very glad to meet you
and if you reached out with your hand
to shake hands with him, he
would not shake your hand.
He had learned and he
had remembered something.
And that was because
he was able to remember
about the pinprick through
his procedural system
of the basal ganglia, that deposit,
sets of links in long-term memory
and that's why Henry could
not remember you or your face
but kinda remember that you are associated
with a handshake that is a big aoi
and so this procedural kind of learning
is actually like half of what we learn,
anything that we have to know really well
so that we don't really
wanna have to think about it,
like our native language for example,
we learn that procedurally
and that means that we
can speak extemporaneously
without having to think about
what we're actually saying.
And this is why for example,
let's say that you have
a simultaneous translator
or a translator who has
learned another language,
but it's not their native language.
It can actually be exhausting to translate
because you're often using
that declarative system
to think about things
whereas if you can just think about it
using your procedural system,
speaking in your native language,
it's not exhausting at
all because it's habitual
and you've got those sets of
links in procedural memory.
So, what this means is,
for learners, it is invaluable to develop
not only declarative kind of
factually related sets of links
in long-term memory, oh,
the date is this date
but also procedural sets of links.
So, this relates more to
like complex patterns.
How do you work math problems like this
as opposed to like another, as
opposed to like a third type?
How do you work all of
these kinds of problems?
You only develop the intuition
or seeming intuition of how
to do these kinds of problems
by practicing with lots
of different types,
getting lots of feedback
about whether or what you've done
to try to solve that problem is correct
and then trying again
and interleaving different,
closely related examples
so that you can see for example,
what is the geometric distribution
versus what is the negative
binomial distribution
versus what is the binomial distribution
and you can actually see when you use one,
when you use another and
how to do these things.
Oftentimes in classes,
what you actually learn is,
"Okay, here's an example
of binomial distribution."
And you do like a dozen problems of it
and you think you know it really well
but then you're faced with a new problem
that's negative binomial and you're like,
"No, wait a minute, what's going on here?"
If you haven't practiced
to train the difference
between these things,
then you don't know what
those differences are
and this is where a lot of practice
with your procedural learning
system can be so valuable
and I have to ask you,
what does Khan Academy do
to help learners with
their procedural learning?
- Well, what you were just describing,
hopefully those out listening
have heard a lot of things
that sound like Khan Academy
because we are absolutely based in...
Well, some folks know us as videos,
the exercises that are woven in
and linked to those videos
are key to the learning
experience at Khan Academy
and so as we see those exercises
as the active learning,
that practice component
you were talking about
where students can start
doing a number of problems
that are kind of similar to each other
and then somewhat different
and then, when they get to
having done a couple few of those
in a row, we actually give them problems
that have a couple of
different related skills
and they have to figure
out which one to use,
which one to apply
as kind of the extra
added layer of difficulty.
But essentially, that is the key thing
that we at Khan Academy see
as one of our main purposes
as a supplemental tool
for students in classrooms
and working on their own
to be able to provide that extra practice
so those links you were talking about,
those neural connections are
forming and getting stronger.
- Well, you really could
not be more in line
with what brain science is revealing
about how we should learn.
It does make me laugh
because notice how you
framed what you're doing,
it's like closely related
concepts that you're interleaving.
Sometimes teachers can
unwittingly get the idea
that interleaving means
just having something
and then having something
different but it isn't.
The key to interleaving
is it has to have...
You want students to notice the difference
between closely related patterns.
So, like, if you're teaching punctuation
and you interleave that
with things like
questions about metaphors,
that's not interleaving,
they're too far apart.
But if you talk about what's a metaphor
as opposed to a simile,
as opposed to an analogy,
now you're talking interleaving
so that's when you really start building
that procedural intuitions
with the closely related,
interleaved concepts.
- Great, so, as usual time is flying.
I wanna get to a couple of
questions that are coming in
from the folks that are watching.
I know.
So, it's funny you just talked
about similes and metaphors.
This is kind of a different
question but relates to it.
So, Susanna Garcia
Domingos from YouTube asks,
"Hello, Dr. Oakley,
could you please share
about the use of metaphors
and analogies to help people learn?
How could we effectively use them?"
- Oh, Gemini, can I share something
that would show this idea
very, very clearly if I can?
Come on Bob, tell me you can...
Or is it possible?
If it isn't--
- I don't think we can do a screen share.
- If you wanna point someone to somewhere
where they could look that bit
or hang on whatever
- So, here's the thing.
So, you create this set
of interlinked neurons
and you can just think of it like
you've got this nice,
little, golden necklace
with nice links between them.
So, let's say you know
what the flow of water is.
That actually in your own mind,
that is a set of linked neurons
and it's sort of like a complex set
so you've got this net of neurons
and that net is your understanding
that you've developed
ever since you were a little
kid watching water flow.
Now let's say that
you're trying to explain
how electrical current flows.
So that's like electrons
moving the other way,
then you actually think of electron...
But anyway, so it's
the motion of particles
which is somewhat analogous
to the flow of water.
Because you already have that set of links
for understanding how water flows,
you can much more easily understand
the flow of electrical current
because it's got a lot of
the same, those key ideas
of movement of particles.
So, it turns out that using metaphors
or using analogies are a similarity,
a likeness between something you know
and something you wish to convey
is an incredibly powerful tool
in education and in learning.
And it's in part related to a theory
called neural reuse theory
which means if we've already built
our understanding of something,
we can reuse some of those
same neurons to help us better
and more easily understand
new ideas and new concepts.
So, sometimes people will say, "Yes"
but the analogy breaks down after a while,
the metaphor breaks down.
If you get to a quantum level
in how electrical current flows,
it's not at all like how
water flows and that's true.
But whenever a metaphor breaks down,
you just get a new metaphor.
And indeed, Emanuel Derman
who's a great physicist turned
financial analyst said that
all mathematical equations
are simply metaphors.
And I think there's a great
deal of truth to that.
So anyway, I'm a keen
proponent of metaphors
and especially visual metaphors
because they can help students
learn so much more quickly.
- Great, thank you.
Let's have...
I think we have time for one more
from Akshat Doobie on YouTube.
"I've been struggling with
making habits for a long time.
What are some tips to help
me create a new habit?"
- Just do it over and over and
over and over and over again.
I mean, I know that sounds silly
but let me just give you an example.
Let's say that you are driving
home, you're driving home,
you've done it a hundred times before
and you think of something else that day
that is really important
like you should have put
something into a report
and you forgot to do it.
Well, 45 minutes later, you arrive at home
and you can't even
remember how you got home.
Well, how did you get home then?
I mean, how do you learn to do that?
Well, you have driven home so many times
that actually your procedural
system has learned it
and you can drive home
without even thinking
about it as a consequence
unless somebody does
something bizarre in a car
right ahead of you or something.
So, what this means is, in
our daily lives, for example,
let's see, I wanted our daughters,
our two daughters to have all
career doors open for them.
So, for many, many children,
mathematics is not fun
and when you try to make
it fun, it may become fun
but it may not be necessarily
a good learning experience.
So, I just made a habit
of 20 minutes every day,
our girls did some extra math practice.
We used Kumon Math,
I think if Khan Academy had
been around at that time,
we would have been using Khan Academy
but they did this extra practice
interleaving closely related concepts
and they didn't wanna
do it most of the time,
it was sometimes pushing and so forth
but it was the habit
that I developed in them,
you just do this for 20 minutes
a day, that's who you are.
And, Byrgaly, our older
daughter who's, let's say,
not a natural talent with mathematics
finished her medical residency at Stanford
and it's this early training,
that just sort of a little
bit of extra practice,
20 minutes a day, that
habit actually helped her
so she did have all
career doors open for her
even if you might have said early on,
"This kid's, she's not gonna
go anywhere with math."
Our younger daughter was
more natural at math,
she simply hated it but
she had to do it anyway
and she went off and she became an artist
and now she's back at school
getting her master's degree in statistics.
So, it did keep those doors open for all.
So, for me, Duolingo, I use Duolingo
and I practice my Spanish
or my Russian each day
and it helps a lot.
- Great, so, I think that's
a good theme to close on,
that Keep practicing, it
builds those pathways,
it builds those skills.
Thank you for joining us today.
Again, the new book, publication
day today, congratulations,
"Uncommon Sense Teaching."
For those of you that are
looking for some new guidance
in the classroom, I highly recommend it.
Definitely pick it up and get some,
both the suggestions
and the why that these
are the suggestions to try
in your classroom.
So, thanks so much for
being with us today,
thanks to all of you in the audience
and we'll see you next time.
- Oh, and our daughter
actually got into statistics
because she took a lot
of Khan Academy courses,
watched so many videos a day
so I should add that in, so
that's actually true story.
She said, "Sal Khan got
me through calculus."
So, thank you.
- Thank you for that good
endorsement of what we're doing,
we'd love to hear stories from people
who have used our materials.
Thank you.
- Thank you.